all right let's get into the mailbag
even including a thanksgiving greetings
from some
i guess unexpected people maybe
depending on your perspective um from
last week
if you want to have a chance at
participating in the mailbag you can
email info davidpakman.com i do want to
say this again because unfortunately
we're dealing more and more with this
if you're emailing every day
we're probably no longer seeing your
messages when people email in too much
and there are people sending messages
multiple times a day
where there's no chance you're going to
be in the mailbag the emails are just
auto auto uh
sort of filtered
into a folder
and um
you know let let's
quality over quantity let's keep it
there info davidpakman.com let's go
right into the first one which is
you're a loser and a racist and of
course almost mandatory
that you're
which is supposed to be you are
contracted to you apostrophe re
misspelled as y-o-u-r
my loser and a racist doesn't make a lot
of sense i don't know when it became law
that when you write hate mail you have
to put in the wrong you're
um but certainly we are seeing that very
strongly in our email bag so you're a
loser and a racist thank you
thomas wrote in about socialism this is
a good email actually thomas writes
your remarks seem to indicate that the
u.s doesn't have socialism if we take
the broad definition the u.s has plenty
social security medicare minimum wages
etc and more than enough government
support for large industries a socialism
that predates that for the majority
one political party has been trying for
decades to eradicate socialism for 70 to
80 of the people which would leave more
wealth to shovel up to the plutocracy if
we don't take the broad meaning of the
word shouldn't we also drop the broad
meaning of capitalism vulture capitalism
vampire capitalism mom and pop
operations etc corporations and the
financial behemoths that use wealth of
the capital class to rake more of it up
for them a lot of really good points
here in points that we've made when when
i say
the united states is not a socialist
country
what i mean is that at the top level
socialism including a socialized
ownership of the means of production is
not the model
thomas is completely correct that in
certain areas
we do have
socialized services
and you can even include more
uh
police in most places some places have
like sort of like private police forces
but police in most places
fire fighters in most places
uh social security is a socialization of
sorts
uh medicare yes we we have the military
um and so
when we say we are not a socialist
country
we mean one thing about it we mean when
the right says it's socialist to
have obama phones as uh jesse lee
peterson once told me or whatever this
is not a socialist country or government
at the top level but we have socialist
elements within it uh for sure next
email is from bruce
bruce says david what i'm wondering is
when is elon musk going to hop on one of
these b arcs that he is creating
and going to crash into venus which is
the planet he wants the earth to become
yeah um there's a lot more
anti-elon musk sentiment in the email
lately
um
and i did a if you're interested in the
topic of elon musk and tesla from the
electric vehicle standpoint on friday on
black friday i did a stream where we did
a lot of different things but one of the
things is i did talk about my increased
it's not dissatisfaction but
less enthusiasm about tesla as the
future of electric vehicles i think
tesla was an early mover
and when it comes to the range of their
vehicles they're second to none but
there are other companies including
general motors audi
just about all of them
that are generally speaking better at
building vehicles
and i talked about where i believe
tesla is going to start having problems
it's less about the personality call
around elon musk but if you're
interested in that topic check out
that live stream from black friday very
very powerful live stream
um okay here's a thanksgiving greeting
maybe you guys did not expect on uh
thursday thanksgiving i got a email
an email
from jimmy from philly that furious
angry trumpist who calls in
and he said simply happy thanksgiving
there was no attack there was no insult
there was no slur or the homophobia or
transphobia
that we've come to expect from jimmy
from philly simply happy thanksgiving he
does email me sometimes uh just um
just to say hello so not sure how many
of you are surprised by that
but i did receive that
next question is from jeff jeff wright
in writes in and says why the big
microphone david sir
i see people online using tiny lavalier
mics and they sound fine
or those that wrap around your face
i know this is a stupid question but why
do you use such a big mic at least it
doesn't obscure your mouth like other
youtubers i hope you're not compensating
for anything big fan and website member
yet you know i've talked about this
before um there's a couple different
reasons that i've stuck with the big mic
when we years ago when we tried the
clip-on lavalier mics
we didn't have the ones that sounded
that good so i'm completely open to
switching to a lav mic
if someone can recommend to me one that
really will sound as good as one of
these larger condenser microphones but
a lot of people just listen to this show
via the audio podcast
i don't want to have damaged sound
quality that's one reason the second
reason is our main studio is very well
treated from the standpoint of
echo and
deadening the room and all of that stuff
our backup studio which we now have is
not
and using a lavalier mic when i've
tested it is insanely echoey and when
traveling i've got some travel upcoming
where i'm going to be doing the show
from different locations it's so
unpredictable what the room
treatment is going to be you might be
you know in a could be a hotel room with
those kind of like padded
almost like it's just it's like a
painting but it's just padded fabric you
know it's kind of like in now
which helps to deaden the sound and
carpets and whatever or it can be really
echoey because it's so unpredictable the
large canister microphone just seems to
sound better but
if someone can recommend a good love
that really will will perform well
in all of these scenarios i will switch
to it trust me when i travel and i bring
the big boy
i think every time it would be great to
have a tiny little microphone all right
jeff so i hope that's a comprehensive
enough answer
this is a very sad email from matthew
matthew says
conspiracy theory aunt or he's from new
york so i guess he would say ant
i'm matthew from new york
my whole family is diverse republican
members trumpists trump haters
don't like the rhetoric but will vote
for policies and just classic republican
members but all as i know vaccinated
except one my aunt
she has conspiracy theories about the
vaccine and the left so much
that she thinks trump is saying get the
vaccine
as a reverse psychology technique i
don't know what to do i don't want to
cut off but i'm feeling i feel like i'm
enabling her every time i talk to her
about politics what do i do you know i
get these questions all the time i can't
tell you matthew what to do
you have to decide what is the emotional
psychological mental health
impact
of being in contact with someone who is
so disconnected from reality versus how
much do you value the relationship with
her and what effect it would have to cut
her off
in terms of the relationships between
you and other people in the family i
can't answer that question for you what
i think is very interesting about this
particular conspiracy theory
is that it's an example of an in you
it's indefeasible it's unfalsifiable
right
um because
if trump were to say don't get the
vaccines
a lot of these folks would say see
trump is saying don't get it
and if trump says get it
anyone like matthew's aunt can say it's
reverse psychology what he really is
wanting people to do is not to get it
even though he's saying that you should
get it so
that's any kind of unfalsifiable claim
like that is very very tough because no
matter what he says
they come to the same conclusion so i
don't really have advice on the personal
thing but it is a very tough conspiracy
theory to deal with
next message came in via facebook
i don't suppose you would be interested
to hear or see this but the restaurants
in my town have started to put let's go
brandon on the bottom of tickets i
figured you know what it means
guy mon oklahoma pub on the bricks yeah
i've seen reports of this where
you go you know oftentimes at
restaurants
the receipt
has some kind of message at the bottom
sometimes it's thank you for your
business
happy holidays
thank you for coming we appreciate you
stuff like that there are some
restaurants that have started to put at
the very bottom of the rest of the
restaurant receipt let's go brandon
which is of course code for f joe biden
it's one of the cringiest new right-wing
phrases which they think is super clever
and it's not um i wouldn't go to such a
restaurant if i ever saw that at the
bottom of
a receipt i would never go back uh
everybody's got to decide for themselves
what to do
last one coming in via twitter
this user says david pakman
you seem to suffer from a pretty severe
case of autism
that has only intensified over the years
it's hilarious that you'd call anyone a
doofus referring to the judge in the
written house case it's hilarious that
you'd call anyone a doofus how hard were
you bullied growing up or were you just
socially awkward to the point of
becoming socially crippled
very very big shot across the bow
of course if anybody knew about my first
jobs which i've talked about here on the
show
uh
which were very very much
sales oriented
dependent on rapidly
reading social cues and
building rapport with people you've just
met
you might come away with a different
conclusion but a very interesting
response here
to me saying that written house judge
was wacky wasn't he so congratulations
to everybody who got their messages into
the mailbag today you can write in
info
davidpakman.com
you might notice all of the emails that
get on our one paragraph so the
multi-page emails as much time as may
have gone into them which we appreciate
very much they're not going to make it
onto the mailbag and we have a fantastic
bonus show coming up for you today sign
up at joinpacman.com you will get access
to the bonus show instantly as well as
the commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show we will see you then